ladies and gentlemen it's a great honor
now to present a former Oscar winner
miss Joan Fontaine
the Academy has given me the rare
privilege of presenting a gentleman
we've been honored many times by both
his profession and his country Sir
Laurence Olivier
thank you ladies and gentlemen it's
great honor to be introduced by a little
lady who knocked me so far off the
screen in Rebecca some years ago I
believe I'm to be what is known in the
trade as a change of pace that is to say
as somebody entirely devoid of humor
sometimes a comfort in this day I've
ever hoped for change and suspected
decay when the expected takes place when
the platitude exactly fits the occasion
therefore with resignation not on mixed
with relief that I can wholeheartedly
and generally say to you that I am very
very happy to be here tonight after the
business at hand resent the coveted
Oscar for the Foreign Language Film
Award our Miss Cyd Charisse mr. Robert
Stack
will you start placing the nominees our
arms and the man HR so-called he Gold
Bond productions Germany la venganza
Yeon pollution is cinematography cos
Spain
my uncle Specter grey alter films in
association with films del Santo France
the road a year long Agron film
Yugoslavia the usual unidentified fees
lots vie des sense it Netta
Italy will you announce the winner
please mr. Stan the winner is my uncle's
specter gray auditory Award for the
French film my uncle Jacques Tati
whatever I would say few words with my
really bad English
I find that the people who speak worth
English want to talk more than the
others but for my first visit in a in
Hollywood I feel I am doing fine and I
want to tell you something you may for
myself is very important Hollywood it's
a town at the beginning of comedy
slapstick pantomime and I will remember
all the names from Max Annette to
Chaplin to everyone I'm still making
pantomime in my little corner myself
tonight I know that even Hollywood they
have not done so many funny pictures I
would not be here tonight so for all
those great comedians tonight I'm not
the uncle and the nephew and I respect
very much